hey what is up guys i'm pbhd here and
this this
is
the ipad pro the huge ipad in the flesh
uh this is sort of like my second first
impressions of it so my original
impressions were at that apple event a
number of weeks ago when you know i got
all the footage of it and i was getting
my first hands on of how it feels and
how it looks but this is the first time
i've had it in house so i'm going to be
putting my own apps on it and this is
the beginning of that testing so i'm
going to try to do this entire video
without any that's what she said jokes
but it's hard to overstate just how huge
this tablet is so ipad pro is rocking a
12.9 inch display with a resolution of
2732 by 2048 so for those keeping track
that's more than a 12-inch macbook more
than a 13-inch retina macbook pro and
more than a 15-inch retina macbook pro
so it's super sharp and bright and it's
very very large and when compared to
these other ipads you know i kind of i
talked about this with the iphone 6 plus
versus the iphone 6. there are a couple
of inherent benefits just from being
bigger so you get a much bigger battery
i still have to test the life of it but
it has a 10
300 milliamp hour battery so i have a
feeling it'll probably last for a very
long time and all that extra space
inside also benefits the speakers so now
this ipad has stereo speakers on both
sides so a pair on each side and they
get very loud and sound fantastic the
stereo image is something else since the
speakers are so far apart now with a
tablet this big you also have some weird
quirks about it being so big with the
bezels kept the same size the tablet is
overall pretty freaking huge and can get
very tiring to hold in one hand for more
than a little while the weight itself is
spread evenly throughout so it isn't top
heavy but it's still 1.57 pounds so it's
one of the heavier tablets out there and
the icon spacing and the home button
just make it look a little comical to
not have like any widgets on the home
screen of ios or anything to take
advantage of all that extra screen real
estate on the home screen as soon as you
get into an app you'll immediately see
all the benefits of those pixels apps
have more columns there's more readable
text on the screen the keyboard gets
bigger and easier to type on you have
the numbers dedicated there and web
browsing just shows way more of each web
page and multitasking in ios 9 will have
way more space so yeah it's just
something about the home screen seems a
little bit off fun fact the distance
between the icons on the ipad pro is
more pixels wide than the entire screen
of the original iphone anyway one area
where the ipad pro flexes its muscles is
in the performance department as you'd
expect this thing is a monster with
apple's new a9x chip and four gigabytes
of ram benchmarks off the charts and
everything has been buttery smooth for
the couple of days i've been messing
with this thing and i think that this
along with the newest iphones have
performance so good that it just kind of
removes any lag and it just showcases
ios at its finest just what it's
supposed to be now one pretty big
question a lot of people are asking
about the ipad pro is can it replace
your laptop can it really be a pro
machine we have the ipad air we have the
ipad mini and if they just called this
the ipad xl that would probably be the
end of that conversation but they're
calling it the pro and they're actually
bolstering that with a number of
first-party accessories which i will
show you that'll sort of give us a
better idea of what apple is trying to
show that the ipad pro can do so the
first of those is the keyboard smart
cover so it uses the smart connector at
the bottom of the ipad pro and a couple
of magnets to snap into place and pair
and while it's closed it looks like a
normal ipad smart cover a normal case
except for the fact that it's a little
bit thicker than normal and it's on a
huge ipad but when you unfold it and
refold it it becomes a pretty average
looking ipad keyboard and the keys have
about the same travel as a 12-inch
macbook keyboard and the layout is
almost the same too uh you know slightly
rounded keys slightly i guess more click
than the 12-inch macbook but overall
having a physical keyboard is good for
people who type a lot so people who want
to use the microsoft office suite or
maybe even apple zone iwork suite or
type a lot of emails because you get to
do all this in a more ergonomic position
so that you don't cover up half of the
screen with your hands while you type
but then again it doesn't have quite the
same ergonomics as a dedicated laptop or
even something that's purposefully
designed from the ground up to have a
detachable keyboard i'm not saying it
falls off your lap or anything but it's
definitely no surface book and then the
second accessory the one that's gotten
the most attention and that's so hard to
get your hands on right now the hundred
dollar apple pencil apple has said over
and over again that these things work
together really well better than
third-party styluses and yeah that is
true first of all this is how it charges
and pairs yeah an accident waiting to
happen but we'll just go with it and
once you do that and get it going the
super simple stylus works pretty well
with palm rejection to make writing and
drawing work well on the ipad pro the
tip is thinner than most third-party
styluses since it's not mimicking
another finger so you can get a little
bit more precise with it and the amount
of delay is almost zero so you've
noticed there's practically no latency
when drawing and when apps and things
actually show up on the display so i
just kind of wish it was a little more
robust i kind of wish it had an eraser
but the apple pencil is a very specific
tool that a very small group of people
will buy for the extra 100
just cross your fingers that this thing
will be more functional when more apps
are built to take advantage of it so if
you're still looking at this ipad pro
and wondering who is this for don't
worry you're not alone in fact right now
i'm actually kind of just loving using
it as a huge ipad which is awesome for
consumption watching videos with the
incredible display and speakers is
fantastic catching up on youtube and
like reading articles is a massively
improved experience thanks to that
bigger real estate and all those pixels
as for production that's a work in
progress but it will get better and i'm
sure those who spend the hundred dollars
on a stylus will be committed to making
that work so there you have it that's
the beginning my early thoughts and
impressions of the ipad pro and the
first party accessories this is the
first apple mobile device that i can't
hold all the way around with one hand
not that that matters but yeah let me
know what you guys want to see in the
full review of it in the comments
section down below if you have any
thoughts or things you want to know
about it and that'll be it thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace